l'ips c'est fini cette phrase mais
souvent prononcée semble être devenu
réalité aujourd'hui 3000 1976 il ya tout
juste quarante cinq ans après des années
de combat
l'entreprise l'ip spécialisée dans
l'horlogerie est mise en liquidation
la société basée à besançon a été l'un
des symboles de la désindustrialisation
de la france dans les années 70 l'ips
c'est d'abord un savoir faire à la
française
fin des années 50 début des années 60 la
marque est à son apogée
mais à partir des années 70 les choses
se gâtent libre doit faire face à la
concurrence étrangère la première erreur
de lips et d'avoir méprisé trop
longtemps la montre à bon marché
celle qu'on vit aujourd'hui dans les
bureaux de tabac ou les papeteries ici
on fabrique et on fabrique toujours le
cadeau de mariage la montre du premier
communiant produits de qualité n'est
chère l'ip ne s'en remet pas et dépose
le bilan en avril 73 un conflit social
s'installe en attente d'un repreneur
les 1300 salariés essentiellement des
femmes vont inventer un nouveau concept
d'entreprise celui de l'autogestion ils
occupent les usines confisqué le
matériel
il organise des ventes sauvages de
montres pour se payer qui n'est pas
question de brader il n'est pas question
de solder les montres et des questions
de continuer la fabrication comme par le
passé 110 ans les responsables qui nous
ont abandonnés après des semaines
d'autogestion l'occupation de leasing
prend fin le 14 août 1973 à 6h du matin
des crs investissent luz il est des
loges des salariés
c'est le mal au coeur
ah oui c'est combien de jours que vous
reteniez là-dedans 119,4 ça faisait
quatre mois
le 17 mai la sphère l'ip ne s'arrête pas
là la france entière se mobilise pour
sauver l'entreprise
le 29 septembre 1973 des dizaines de
milliers de personnes parfois venus de
l'étranger manifeste à besançon c'est la
marche des 100000 malgré cette
mobilisation
l'activité est toujours à l'arrêt pierre
messmer alors premier ministre là sur
l'ip c'est fini pourtant la lutte
continue chez les travailleurs et ça
paie un repreneur et trouver
l'entreprise rouvre ses portes le 11
mars 1974 et une en chargé d'histoire
qu'est ce que ça vous prêts joie de
courte durée
1976 nouveau conflit social libre des
pauses encore une fois le bilan
l'entreprise est liquidée avant d'être
acheté une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui
après des années difficiles une partie
de l'usiné se trouve toujours à besançon
[Musique]